[Music]
farmers and ranchers have many
responsibilities
two important responsibilities are
producing food and protecting natural
resources such as soil water air plants
and animals these objectives are not
mutually exclusive and in fact often
complement each other even so producers
do have to balance the ways in which
they allocate time money and other
resources this video explores how
producers balance and achieve
environmental goals while managing
animals crops and business this video
introduces some general conservation
practices while outlining specific
practices that are relevant to animal
production manure management and air and
water quality it also highlights the
technical and financial assistance that
may be available for producers to apply
conservation practices
such assistance is offered through the
US Department of Agriculture's Natural
Resources Conservation Service or NRCS
local Soil and Water Conservation
districts or s WCS and other federal
state and local programs
conservation on farms is based on
maintaining or improving productive
agricultural lands and natural resources
farms and ranches of all types and sizes
can benefit from NRCS conservation
practices to improve or preserve soil
health air and water quality and
wildlife habitat on and around farms
these components make up productive and
functional ecosystems which in turn have
economic environmental and community
value that extends beyond the farm
with these elements of sustainability in
mind NRCS and others support producers
as they make decisions about
conservation practices for their farms
although certain conservation practices
are implemented to help meet regulatory
requirements the majority are adopted
voluntarily but even when required the
specific combinations of measures are
usually chosen by the producers
themselves to meet individual needs and
site-specific conditions many NRCS
conservation practices apply to animal
agriculture for example producers can
store manure and plan application to
achieve the right amount in form of
nutrients at the right time in the right
place for growing crops manage livestock
grazing to promote healthy soil and
vegetation and plant cover crops to
retain topsoil
and reduce nutrient losses such
practices support productive livestock
and cropping systems while also
protecting water quality and promoting
soil health conservation practices have
the potential to significantly benefit
Natural Resources although some
practices can save money in the long
term by reducing fuel or fertilizer use
they can also require the producer to
invest financial resources upfront
farmers and ranchers can access
technical and financial assistance
through their local and rcs office to
help offset the cost of implementing
certain conservation practices
the local NRCS office is a valuable
resource where NRCS and conservation
district staff technical service
providers and other local partners work
directly with producers to select design
and implement conservation practices
they ensure conservation practices not
only follow the state's technical
standards but are also carefully
customized to account for the unique
soils location management and needs of
an individual farm there is rarely a
one-size-fits-all approach when it comes
to conservation practices tailoring
conservation practices to the specific
farm and local resource concerns
maximizes the benefits to Natural
Resources NRCS and the producer develop
a contract that specifies exactly what
will be done to the site and when the
contract also specifies the amount of
financial assistance provided to the
producer the assistance can come from a
variety of sources in addition to NRCS
nrcs the conservation district or other
partners continue to provide technical
assistance throughout the process
checking in on the progress and quality
of the work
more specific details on some practices
used on animal agriculture operations
are presented in the next video in this
module conservation practices are one of
several ways that farmers and ranchers
work towards sustainability to ensure
productive agriculture and healthy
natural resources for generations to
come
[Music]